faire bouillir de l'eau une chose si
simple qui peut devenir compliqué
lorsque vient le temps de choisir une
bouilloire
notre expert Frédéric Chabot a testé 12
bouilloires électriques six modèles à
température réglable et si sa
température fixe quand on parle d'une
bouilloire sans fil c'est pas tout à
fait vrai parce qu'elles ont toutes un
fil mais c'est la carafe qui est
amovible sans fil en effet aussi très
pratique d'avoir une carafe qui est sans
fil c'est pas dans les jambes donc ici
on a le seul modèle qu'on a testé avec
fil si je veux remplir la bouilloire
sous le robinet et j'ai toujours le film
qui est dans les pas
maintenant tous les appareils qu'on a
testé sont menus d'un système qui arrête
le chauffage dès que l'eau au bout en
fait le test le plus important c'est de
savoir à quelle vitesse l'eau va
bouillir
notre expert a fait deux tests en
calculant le temps pour atteindre le
point d'ébullition dans 2 minutes 50
secondes
le premier test avec 500 ml d'eau et
ensuite avec la capacité maximale des
bouilloires soit 1,7 litre d'eau
toujours à la même température
[Musique]
avec une petite quantité d'eau la
bouilloire Salton a été la plus rapide
et pour une bouilloire à pleine capacité
c'est la Hamilton Beach qui a le mieux
performé si voir le niveau d'eau vous
importe les modèles en verre seront un
bon choix mais d'autres types de
matériaux proposent aussi d'excellents
système
que je souhaite
sur les deux côtés puis on voit très
clairement de la quantité d'eau que je
mets dans la carafe
tandis que la black and Baker est
graduée à l'intérieur pas très pratique
que votre bouilloire soit en verre en
plastique ou en acier inoxydable
attention à l'accumulation de calcaire
pour éviter qu'il se retrouve dans notre
théière ou dans notre tasse les
appareils ont des petits filtres on a
des filtres ici qui sont parfois un peu
difficile à retirer et qui peuvent
parfois avoir des mailles assez
grossières contrairement à certains
autres appareils où le film fait très
facile à enlever et à remettre j'imagine
qu'on cherche des mailles très très
fines très très fine en effet
quelques modèles sont munis d'un filtre
anti-calcaire intégré dans le couvercle
une fois que mon filtre est sale je vois
un peu difficilement comment je vais
faire pour le nettoyer je devoir aller à
l'évier faire couler de l'eau ici le lot
va couler partout mon dépôt de quelqu'un
va retomber c'est beaucoup moins
pratique qu'un filtre qui est retirable
et en plus souvent dans ces modèles là
il y a un espace entre le film qui la
paroisse
de passer quand même on a toujours eu
des éléments comme ça qui sont immergés
dans l'eau et qui sont très difficiles à
nettoyer aussi depuis quelques temps
maintenant on a des éléments qui sont
intégrés donc à l'intérieur de la base
donc sous le fond de la carafe donc
beaucoup plus facile à nettoyer on a
d'autres modèles comme ceux ici qui sont
un peu des folles difficiles à ouvrir et
qui se ferme facilement mais il faut
absolument que le couvercle soit bien
enfoncé sinon l'élément chauffe
le modèle Ricardo prend les airs d'une
théière avec son infuseur inséré dans la
bouilloire
[Musique]
c'est une bonne idée mais qui
demanderait un peu plus de travail pour
que ça soit vraiment pratique
[Musique]
les amateurs de thé qui souhaitent une
température précise voudront opter pour
un modèle à température variable
ce qui est assez surprenant c'est selon
le fabricant et on peut tous la même
température pour chaque sorte de thé
donc je peux avoir une différence de 5 à
10 degrés pour la même sorte de thé donc
qui dirait dans tout ça et en plus de ça
moi ce qui me fascine le plus c'est que
même si je fais chauffer mon eau à 80
degrés pour un thé spécifique à 80
degrés quand je verse mon eau dans ma
théière ou dans ma tasse je vais prendre
en général 5 à 15 degrés donc même si je
programme mon eau à température parfaite
pour un d une fois rendu dans mon
récipient pour l'infusion l'eau va être
plus froide on est autour de la douzaine
de degrés
on peut faire une infusion à une
température très précise tous les
modèles qui sont programmment aussi ont
une fonction de maintien donc si je
programme mon eau pour qu'elle soit à 90
je la porte à 90 je vais faire autre
chose la température est atteinte quand
je reviens l'eau est à 90 donc à part
pour les amateurs de thé est-ce que ça
vaut vraiment la d'investir dans des
modèles plus complexes je n'arrive pas à
trouver une utilisation autre que le thé
pour avoir de l'eau à 75 degrés ou à 80
degrés Celsius
si l'idée d'une bouilloire à température
variable vous plaît il faudra y mettre
le prix permis celles que le moins de
petits défauts Beach dans les programmes
performes très bien mais c'est assez
cher c'est quand même ça maintenant
en font une bonne aussi qui est moins
cher à 75$ le défaut principal c'est le
tableau d'affichage qui est un peu
Basile c'est vraiment celle qui performe
le mieux mais c'est très cher quand même
à 130$ juste pour faire chauffer de
l'eau sinon dans la catégorie bouilloire
à température fixe la causerie à 58
dollars remplissez fonctions et pour les
petits budgets la toute simple Procter
ça Alex même si elle est munie d'un fil
répondra à votre besoin de chauffer de
l'eau c'est sûr que le couvercle est pas
très pratique mais pour 33$ ça fait
quand même très bien la job
[Musique]